is there anything else you'd want to try
in the future perhaps or any other skill
sets you want to do
because you seem to be up for doing
anything yeah see and that's kind of a
bit of a double-edged sword isn't it
because i want to do everything
but then i start spreading myself a bit
thin i would say yeah
there's so many things i want to do yeah
ways like you you want you want to focus
on one skill and then you're like
maybe this maybe doing this would be fun
maybe doing that would be fun yeah right
exactly that's how it is you know so
like has being a
v tuber affected like your schedule you
know when you're off camera or anything
like that oh for sure i only sleep for
about four hours a night actually
yeah [ __ ] that uh yeah i knew that i
needed at least like
a seven or eight hours otherwise i just
cannot function the next day
i just love sleep too much i understand
yeah and i guess because you're a v tube
you know you don't have to deal with
people being like you look tired you
look tired exactly it's not that
wonderful
eating enough like people just ask me
questions like you always look tired
you look angry no i just always [ __ ]
look angry okay i always look like this
all right sharks on you i am angry
you're right being on trash taste has
made me super self-conscious about the
tiniest things i do
right like the other day i had like i
had like this thread that was just
me drinking like weirdly like taking a
weird sip
and i'm just like do i do i take sips
weirdly is that a thing
i do am i a weird drinker no because we
saw
we saw earlier on the train here right
that like do you know what the most
liked
post on our subreddit is it's the video
of
gaunt from like the sydney episode
drinking a corona
and it's like because like at least like
you know in the cases like gaunt for
instance right like
you almost never made like an irl
appearance in your videos yeah
you've almost always exclusively could
have been once you've gone why'd you
[ __ ] spoil it and show your face
[ __ ] say maybe i will maybe i will one
day maybe i am
being you don't know anyone around you
could be a v tuber and you'd have no
[ __ ] clue
exactly yeah legit like i'm sure there's
like a number of people who like know
you
in real life but probably have no idea
that you're a v tuber right
well sure you know these demons see me
on the street all the time yeah
exactly if they hear a familiar voice
well
welcome i'm not gonna know i'm gonna
keep walking in the other direction i
was having this conversation earlier
with i can't remember who but
it was it was like imagine if they
perfect like voice synthesizers
right actually if you've seen a
doughbays one it's scary it's actually
scarily good
is it yeah yeah they only need like a
small sample and it can like mimic your
voice
like perfect but they haven't released
it because i think they're scared too
yeah because i think once they perfect
voice synthesizers and make that like
easily like mask like what's the weather
that's produced mass-produced
and easily downloadable yeah then it's
[ __ ] over yeah
because then everyone could be a cute
anime girl right i've got to show you
this clip it's so scary they have like
one person like have a
say a sentence and then they're able to
like make them say whatever like
perfectly yeah
it's so creepy the future isn't like my
job's gonna be gone
you can't even really trust anything
that you hear anymore after that too
yeah like deep fakes man like i'm glad
deep fakes are being used for like
[ __ ] memes right now or like damn it
i think you're [ __ ] retired or
whatever yeah but man
because i remember first seeing how
realistic it is and i'm like this is
this is [ __ ] dangerous in the wrong
ksi oh my god i gotta show you guys off
screen it's so funny
it was like ksi doing the harriet
cooking oh yeah oh yes yes i have seen
that yeah
it's so good yeah because there's also
like that uh
there's also that like japanese like
tech group that made that
you know like that uh the virtual like
model have you seen that one
it's like it's it was really big i
forgot what the name of it was it was
like saya or like sayu
you're just like you're just like
worried about your employment over here
yeah no
basically it's this like hyper realistic
3d model of this japanese girl
and legit like on first glance it
legitimately looks like just a regular
girl because
she also made her manage to move and
like smile and emote
like a real person and it's just man
japan man
they did they just got the ways to bring
dude you get that
you put a [ __ ] adobe like voice
synthesizer on top of that and you
basically just have like a legit
virtual person no wonder no one's having
babies in this country
why have sex when i can just program a
baby